let's bring them out here
first of all Marshawn Lynch from the
Seattle Seahawks Marshawn good to see
you
what's up chief are you thank you so
much for being here yes Lord
you ready to go okay to do he's been a
long time since I first got down
I'm button-mashing for Shoto look he
talking [ __ ] to was you freestyling they
make women monkeys sitting oh my god
Africa's coming out of the ground that's
hella nasty don't see that I got a weak
stomach I thought that was fantastic
get that little blimp you know I'm
talking about that come over there look
booth and I'll be smashing through [ __ ]
like so smooth so it's mob until the end
I don't know either one of you were
talking about it's serious though I
understand I got the movie off the back
I'm gonna rock with cut though I'm
trying o to cut though you know tell my
[ __ ] just sound cool don't shake her
sorry
she I win I pushed the [ __ ] out of him
in the back with an uppercut oh oh you
see that that was hands down my driver
hands but Oh cuz active talking about
what's happening good monsters you real
did you real in the field oh you were
gonna just beat me up what I looked like
wait if you think you can see your boy
come talk to your boy one time I put
hands on you two
if bees up here see was hanging to do it
again Oh haggis
pants pants I respect you a penalty nice
- how long bro yo lady go wings
oh she tripping right there she got the
amber rose hair right
she blew a bubble and she blew from be
what point-blank wait a minute so in
broad daylight rock-a-bye baby
yeah haha that's that new jack city wigs
okay Irish Oh
chuckle neck is that right brush she
just punched you in in that yeah that
bang you can't do that yes the UK like
the game lick the gun licked again god
damn good
hey I feel your pain hold me for daddy
daddy proud
Oh back that air sir back that ass
you're awful lot crossing this ain't no
choice conversation right here flip flop
song yeah what's added I respect your
pimping gangsta I cam that's a good ass
move family I don't know how you did
this
I've been playing this [ __ ] I ain't hit
him with the dougie
that's the dougie there you go you want
now you gonna walk his [ __ ] up
I'm too she against him
that just happened
you